jacques myard bonsoir merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france à vos
côtés gilles casanova expert en
stratégie et en communication messieurs
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors la droite et le
rassemblement national appelle une
législation d'exception
on a vu beaucoup d'émotion aujourd'hui
mais aussi beaucoup de demandes de
fermeté voire de colère jacques myard
dans quel état d'esprit vous êtes ce
soir savez je veux dire une chose je
suis la montée de l'islamisme radical
depuis plus de 30 ans ma premier choc
avec l'islam a été une arrivée en
algérie en septembre 73 où je l'attaché
d'ambassade j'ai pris conscience de ce
qui était une religion holistique
c'est-à-dire globale et qui prenait
totalement un peuple en main et puis
j'ai vu aussi en algérie
ça a commencé avec l'envoi des
intégristes père musulman que boumediene
avait demandé à nasser l'envoi de ses
frères musulmans qui ont lieu
d'enseigner l'arabe comme l'avait
demandé boubée diem renseigner en
réalité l'idéologie frères musulmans et
on a eu une guerre civile quinze ans
après donc c'est un phénomène
international qui s'est développée
depuis longtemps et depuis notamment
1929 avec la naissance des frères
musulmans en egypte et on a les sévères
par laxisme pas une intelligence car
bien évidemment nous connaissons tous
des musulmans parfaitement intégrée qui
posent aucun problème qui sont des
réussites sociales qui sont devenus
ingénieurs
seulement le problème il n'est pas là le
problème c'est que il y as autant
d'islam qu'il y a de musulmans et donc
j'entendais dire dans la par le
gouvernement notamment on va former les
imams
oui très bien vous allez former un imam
qui va être je dirais droit rectiligne
républicain mais à côté il va y avoir un
imam qui veut dire non non non ce que tu
enseignes c'est pas le vrai islam
moi je vais enseigner parce que je fus
un fondamentalisme le vrai islam donc le
ca
alice milliat cinq ou six écoles s'est
développé de manière constante sur notre
territoire et on a fermé les yeux par
laxisme par crainte de montrer du doigt
et de victimiser bien sûr les musulmans
alors ce n'est jamais le cas et on a
laissé faire donc notre responsabilité
totale or comment faire aujourd'hui
c'est simple c'est pas des lois
d'exception il faut rétablir la
souveraineté juridique de la france car
malheureusement a été soulignée
notamment par eric chatel et j'en ai
fait un article sur dans le figaro il y
a aujourd'hui un blocage
on n'est plus gouverné par le
législateur on est gouverné par les
juges
lesquels juges appliquent les textes
qu'on leur a donné
et donc ces textes là il faut pouvoir
sur certains points pas surtout les
arrêter et redonner une interprétation
qui soit conforme à la sécurité des
français
c'est aussi simple que cela donc c'est
pas des lois d'exception c'est rétablir
la souveraineté juridique de la france
notamment il ya deux articles qu'il faut
modifier dans la constitution l'article
55 pour dire la loi française est
supérieur aux traités dès lors qu'elle a
été votée après les traités et
deuxièmement c'est l'article 66 qui a
donné totale liberté au juge judiciaire
pour les expulsions eh bien il faut dire
que les expulsions relève du pouvoir
administratif du gouvernement sous le
contrôle du juge
bien sûr administratif c'est ça qu'il
faut faire
jaurès et la littérature gilles casanova
vous fait vous êtes un fin connaisseur
du monde politique le constat posé par
jacques milliards à l'instant est-ce que
vous faites le même vous de votre côté
il y a deux aspects d'abord j'ai entendu
le premier ministre dire qu'il pensait
que les français attendaient que le
gouvernement réagisse fortement dès
qu'il y aura un attentat pas du tout les
goûts les gouvernements réagissent après
les attentats mais les français ils
espèrent qu'il n'y ait pas d'attentats
et que les gouvernements arrive à
empêcher ces attentats c'est cela qu'ils
attendent du gouvernement et c'est
finalement assez logique
ensuite pour faire cela c'est le
renforcement des services de
renseignement
car il n'y a pas de moyen de savoir ce
qui se passe dans un pays est dans une
mouvance comme cette mouvance djihadiste
sous ses mille formes sans des services
de renseignement qui arrive à entrer
dans le détail de ce qui se passe non
seulement dans les sur les sites
internet mais dans les mosquées mais
aussi ici là et puis jacques myard a
effectivement abordé ces deux questions
d'abord la question de la souveraineté
juridique c'est à dire lorsqu'on adopte
une nouvelle loi si celle ci est
contradictoire à un des nombreux traits
et dans lequel nous sommes emmenés par
notre appartenance à l'union européenne
elle tombe d'elle-même et donc dans ce
cas il ne sert à rien de faire de
nouvelles lois sur ces sujets et puis la
question de l'immigration
nous savons que nous avons un grand
nombre de migrants qui y entre certains
qui justifie tout à fait de recevoir la
protection de la france et d'autres qui
ne le justifient pas vous comprenez que
lorsqu'il y à une guerre et que des gens
s'enfuient de cette guerre pour venir en
europe
il y a des gens de tous les camps qui
s'enfuit et alors ensuite ils se
retrouvent sur notre territoire
certains ont tendance à poursuivre leur
guerre on le voit plus souvent en
allemagne qu'en france et d'autres
viennent défendre leur cause
parce qu'ils étaient
un endroit où les jihadistes ont été
battus ils se sont enfuis pour venir en
europe il poursuivre le djihad en europe
car ils pensent que c'est leur mission
donc il faut être très sensibles à cela
très attentif et avoir des services qui
regarde très en amont les choses
je ne crois pas qu'il faille de lois
d'exception je crois qu'il faut que
l'ensemble des dispositifs de l'état
jouent pleinement leur rôle c'est à dire
que le juge ne considère pas que au nom
du fait qu'à justice serait une justice
de classe et que cette personne qu'on
veut expulser est pauvre et malheureuse
et a bien souffert on ne va pas
l'expulser ça n'est pas exactement cela
le travail du juge c'est de juger au nom
du peuple français et pas au nom de des
convictions qui lui sembla lui être le
progressisme et excite tout le monde
fait son travail
je pense que le soutien des français est
acquis maintenant il ya un autre et
dernier problème dans le monde musulman
français il y a une tendance à compatir
aux malheurs des djihadistes et des
islamistes parce que toute une partie
des intellectuels français qui passent
leur temps dans la repentance a expliqué
que la france criminels contre
l'humanité ici là et ailleurs encourage
des personnes qui sont arrivées
où sont les sur notre sol à partir d'une
origine étrangère notamment d'afrique du
nord mais plus lointaines l'afghanistan
ou l'autre les encourage à penser que la
situation faite aux musulmans serait
comme le dit edwy plenel comparable à
celle faite aux juifs au cours du xxème
siècle dans des années difficiles
c'est absolument faux on a recréé en
france 5 les moyens aux musulmans qui
sont sincèrement épris de religiosité de
spiritualité musulmane
anne pour vivre leur religion tout ça de
moyens ont été mises en oeuvre dans le
cadre de ce que la loi et la laïcité
permet mais en revanche on ne peut pas
changer notre loi on ne peut pas
renoncer à notre laïcité parce que il y
aurait dans les règles de telle ou telle
religion quelque chose qu'ils s'y
opposeraient
est ce que ces lois peuvent changer
justement si on part du principe que
nous sommes en guerre selon eric ciotti
c'est le cas nous sommes en guerre vous
vous rejoignez ou par ces mots d'eric
ciotti jacques millar et je veux dire
une chose
les mots sont dépassées par la réalité
faut quand même être sérieux il y a des
gens qui font la guerre effectivement
aux mécréants que nous sommes c'est
aussi simple que cela
parce que deux sur ce qui vient d'être
dit je voudrais insister sur une chose
c'est qu'en réalité la multiplicité d
islam
aujourd'hui l'islam étant en crise et
qu'il y à une crise qui s'apparente et
c'est récurrent dans l'histoire de
l'islam à une sorte de secte
donc vous ne raisonnez pas les gens de
la secte comme disait j'ai appartenu à 3
commission d' enquête sur les sectes
d'une manière autre qui n'était pas
celle de l'islam vous tombez à un
mauvais moment de votre vie dans la sec
et vous en sortez quand il ya un moment
tout d'un coup je n'ai rien à une
lumière qui se fait mais d'une manière
générale vous ne raisonnez pas par des
arguments rationnels
vous ne pouvez pas convaincre ces gens
là qui sont dans l'erreur
c'est une religion c'est une vision
eschatologique
c'est à dire une vision religieuse qui
fait qu' il croit à ce qu'ils font et
vous ne pourrez pas les en sortir
donc vis-à-vis de ces gens là nous
sommes en guerre
c'est évident et donc c'est pas les mots
c'est simplement les moyens pour y
arriver alors tout à l'heure on disait
qu'il faut agir en amont
je peux vous dire connaissant un peu
l'action que nous avons menée à la der à
la délégation pour le renseignement
dans à l'assemblée nationale nous avons
des services qui font leur travail ils
vont bien sûr empêcher 30 attendra
rihanna qui va passer sous les radars ça
c'est je dirais incontournable vous ne
pouvez pas avoir toujours la vigilance
parfois c'est fortuit
il ya une meilleure coordination du
service tant au niveau des services
français que au niveau européen et même
avec les russes et avec les américains
ce qui est clair c'est qu'il faut bien
comprendre que tant que nous avons une
cinquième colonne sur le territoire
national des gens qui ont une vision
eschatologique qui est celle de vous
tuer parce qu'ils m'en aller au paradis
là ça va devenir difficile il faut pas
se leurrer et donc c'est comme cela il
va falloir malheureusement vivre avec
il y aura encore des morts il ya aucun
doute mais c'est à nous effectivement de
mettre en place tout un système détecter
les signaux faibles
vous savez que healy à ce pas le
registre des personnes radicaliser
lorsque j'étais député il ya simplement
trois ans on en comptait treize mille
aujourd'hui on a vingt mille outils chez
bayala certains cas de 5000 qui sont
vraiment radicaux ces gens là ils n'ont
rien à faire sur le territoire national
on voit on dirait que ces images depuis
nice à l'image de
dommage de recueillement après cet
attentat ce matin à nice donc des gens
qui viennent se recueillir en allumant
des bougies et bien évidemment devant la
cathédrale une scène bien évidemment
plein d'émotions gély casanova on a pu
voir aussi des réactions notamment sur
les réseaux sociaux de personnes qui
disent les hommages c'est bien mais
c'est pas assez ça suffit il faut aller
plus loin gilles casanova qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
ces appels à l'unité ces appels à se
rassembler et bien pour certains ce
n'est pas assez il fallait aller plus
loin
comment on doit s'emparer comment l'état
peut s'emparer du sujet aujourd'hui
aller plus loin ça n'est guère possible
s'il s'agit de supprimer les libertés
vous avez remarqué qu'avec le
confinement qui démarre dans quelques
heures
il n'en reste plus beaucoup donc ça
n'est pas dans la réduction de la
liberté des français que se situe le
problème
mais dans la capacité de répondre aussi
à des questions de fond de notre société
il faut comprendre que ce ne sont pas
toujours des étrangers qui font ces
attentats
ce sont parfois des personnes qui sont
nées en france qui ont la nationalité
française
mais ce sont des personnes qui parce
qu'elle n'arrive pas à donner un sens à
leur vie et c'est de donner un sens à
leur mort et ça c'est terrible parce
qu'une personne qui a décidé d'être
kamikazes on a beaucoup moins de moyens
de l'empêcher d'agir qu'une personne qui
va essayer de faire une action même une
action forte même une action à force
ouverte mais qui ne veut pas y laisser
sa vie
et là si nous sommes face à des
kamikazes c'est plus difficile donc il y
as en amont un travail à faire pour que
notre société retrouve une forme de joie
de vivre qu'elle a perdu pas seulement
avec le corps n'a virus mais qu'elle a
perdu on le voit globalement depuis un
certain nombre d'années où on est dans
ce que
les spécialistes appellent la dépression
française la plupart des citoyens du
monde interrogé par sondage pensent que
l'endroit où vit le mieux c'est la
france et la plupart des français
interrogés par ce sondage pensent qu'il
vit est vu dans un enfer donc il y a là
une dépression spécifique j'y tiens vous
réagissez dans un instant vous terminez
à jean casanova et jacques myard réagira
alléno oui conclut et d'une casanova et
jacques myard vont répondre ans mins je
disais que c'est lié à la façon dont est
organisée dont fonctionne notre société
à la manière aussi
on est les dirigé par une gestion des
choses au lieu du gouvernement des
humains dont on a bien besoin
jacques myard vous voulez réagir oui au
projet le casanova a raison c'est que
c'est une bataille culturelle et il
aimerait que le rapport des hommes
notamment de l'individualisme forcené
qui règne actuellement dans la société
et lui de la mort cela étant moi qui
suis un mécréant
la mort fait partie de la vie mais pour
ces gens là qui sont enfermés dans des
sectes religieuses quelles radicalisme
islamique
ils vont trouver le salut de leur lame
en ayant une lecture littérale
fondamentalisme du coran et tant que
vous ne pouvez pas leur dire que c'est
pas ça mais vous savez je veux dire une
chose c'est extrêmement grave
pourquoi je me souviens dans la
commission denquête où nous avions eu un
jour en face de nous des gens la
scientologie
j'ai un gars de la scientologie qui nous
a dit qu'il est en train de signer un
contrat de travail de deux cents ans
avec la scientologie il le disait
complètement convaincu quand vous avez
ce genre je dirais d'intégration de
falaise dans la tête des gens vous ne
pouvez pas les en sortir par des alpes
non rationnel or aujourd'hui nous sommes
face à des gens qui croient
véritablement que lorsqu'ils vont tuer
un mécréant et bien ils vont retrouver
les vierges dans le paradis c'est
dramatique
alors ils correspondent à une réponse
apportée finalement à ce constat
aujourd'hui alors ce constat vous pouvez
le combattre sur le plan culturel petit
à petit en disant à mon gars arrête de
rêver il faut que bien sûr les musulmans
parce que ce qui va se passer je le sais
ce qui va se passer on a 10 ans 15 ans
de 2de guerre larvée avec tous ces
artistes
et puis il ya un jour où tout d'un coup
ce sont les musulmans eux mêmes qui vont
les chasser un ça va arriver parce que
c'est déjà arrivé dans l'histoire et
donc c'est aux musulmans également de
faire le nettoyage de tous ces
fanatiques et de telle manière que il
retrouve une interprétation de du livre
qu'il soit bien sûr qu'on forme et on
sait très bien que aujourd'hui dans les
pays musulmans
il ya un problème parce que vous avez
des gens comme erdogan qui sont en train
de d'instrumentaliser la religion à des
fins de puissance et ça c'est quelque
chose qui à mon avis il va avoir des
difficultés très rapidement il est
d'abord frères musulmans et à travers
les frères musulmans il recherche la
nostalgie de l'empiré ottoman justement
et ça va casser justement gilles
casanova dans ce contexte international
très tendu un notamment entre la france
et la turquie jacques myard le rappelait
les 27 dirigeants de l'union européenne
appellent au dialogue entre les
communautés et les religions
ça semble assez compliqué c'est possible
selon vous le dialogue est toujours
possible est toujours souhaitable dans
une société il ne faut jamais faire la
politique du pire il ne faut jamais
bloquée et les situations sané l'intérêt
donc un des acteurs en revanche l'effort
qui doit être fait ici c'est un effort
d'éducation de tout
la jeunesse de façon à ce que toute une
classe d'âge puissent être protégés de
la tentation de ces idéologies
totalitaires la religion oui le
totalitarisme non c'est un message qui
doit être développée avec un message de
d'instruction de développement de la
connaissance dans la jeunesse c'est
fondamental victor hugo disait quand on
ouvre une école on ferme une prison
on ferme aussi un camps jihadistes ou un
camp d'une quelconque secte de tueurs ou
de suicidaire oui jacqueline a
effectivement ça passe par l'éducation
et ça pèse vous avez premièrement même
victor hugo on a peut-être ouvert pas
mal d'écoles on n'a pas pour autant
fermer les prisons il faut regarder les
choses telles qu'elles sont la violence
est inhérente à nos sociétés d'une
manière générale mais il faut savoir
bien sûr là la guider et c'est le
dialogue interreligieux
excusez moi du peu vous allez dialoguer
avec l'homme que vous avez en face de
vous ça c'est vrai qui va vous admettre
qui va comprendre ce que vous êtes
mais le type qui est à côté voudra pas
dialoguer avec vous donc pour avoir
renseigné pour mettre allé à plusieurs
reprises notamment au vatican dans des
dans des rapports que j'ai fait je peux
vous dire je peux vous dire que ce
dialogue interreligieux il a rapidement
ses limites
je me souviens d'avoir rencontré un père
blanc qui a été ensuite non sans
l'egypte et on sait bien que il ya des
limites à tout ça j'ai rencontré à el
azhar les imam d'al azhar qui sont des
gens qui sont assez francophilie pôles
de t mais il ya des limites qui ne peut
qu il ne peut pas admettre
donc il est clair que ces deux types de
civilisation et quand monsieur casanova
me fait penser à je l'entends très
mencheviks mais quand vous avez des
bolchéviques qui pousse le bouchon plus
loin et ben vous avez perdu
et ce qui est en train de se passer donc
tant que les bolchéviques auront
haut du pavé dans cette religion qui
permet malheureusement toutes les
interprétations possibles
eh bien vous aurez perdu et on aura la
guerre j'y tiens danover c'est vrai que
c'est ces symboles on se souvient c'est
le pape françois qui avait signé un
document avec le grand imam d'al azhar
ces symboles là ça fonctionne pas c'est
pas reçu par le les citoyens par une
société par le peuple sur le terrain ça
on les voit pas ces symboles là s'ils
sont pas acceptés la question clé
la question clé ce sont les croyants
musulmans
c'est eux qui détiennent la clé au ce1
on assiste c'est d'une manière générale
un recul de la religion l'islam comme la
chrétienté comme toutes les religions
recul très fortement ce qui fait que
ceux qui restent sont beaucoup plus durs
ce ne sont que les noyaux les plus durs
qui restent et ensuite la difficulté que
nous avons c'est dans l'islam de france
tous ceux qui ont envie d'un islam
ouvert comme il voit l'ambiance générale
des mosquées qui n'est pas l'islam
ouvert qui est une sorte d'hégémonie
culturelle de ces islamistes même si
elle n'est pas pratique
elle est culturelle il préfère rentrer
chez eux quitté la mosquée plutôt que de
s'affronter en disant voilà où l'islam
doit aller voilà où l'islam de france
peut aller c'est là notre difficulté
c'est à dire que nous n'avons pas en
france de musulmans qui arrive à tenir
un discours de modernisation de l'islam
un discours qui lisent comment l'islam
peut être compatible avec la république
et igg alliés nous avons des gens qui
disent aux musulmans ce qu'ils doivent
penser et les musulmans n'ont rien à
faire il va être l'intérieur de cette
religion pour pouvoir dire quelque chose
qui soit entendue dans cette religion
sinon on le dit de l'extérieur si un
bouddhiste vient dire un catholique ce
qu'il faut faire au prochain concile le
catholique va l'écouter avec beaucoup de
distance
zac milliard vous êtes confond
tu es à cette problématique dans votre
commune notamment dans les mosquées
non alors j'ai la chance je dirais de ce
côté là en dehors d'un incident d'un
animateur de jeu deux animateurs de
centres de loisirs ou de football d'un
club de tout le monde qui avait refusé
de serrer la main d'une femme parce que
c'était un pic et qui a été
immédiatement débarquer heureusement je
n'ai pas ça mais vous le savez
malheureusement dans les yvelines
maisons laffitte et peut-être une
exception je voudrais revenir sur ce qui
vient des 10 et qui est frappé au coin
du bon sens par monsieur casanova
ce qui est certain c'est que ça peut ça
doit devenir du des musulmans eux mêmes
et ça c'est clair et que ça va prendre
un certain temps parce que aujourd'hui
ceux qui tiennent le haut du pavé dans
l'islam ce sont toujours les extrémistes
même si ils ne seront pas et que en face
les modérés bas ils risquent leur peau
on le sait bien il faut protéger y
compris les imams qui me tiennent des
propos tout à fait compatible avec le
régime républicain
mais ça va durer donc tant qu'on aura
pas entre guillemets écartée je le dis
éliminé c'est d'aller à sortir du
territoire national ces extrémistes qui
tiennent des propos contraires à l'ordre
publique française dans sa totalité
et bien si nous n'y arrivons pas nous
les avons en notre sein et nous allons
les subir pendant un certain temps
jusqu'à ce que peut-être un jour ce sont
les musulmans eux mêmes les modérés qui
tout d'un coup
fort de leur conviction se pose mais ça
va être violent s'oppose directement à
cette minorité agissante et fasciste
jacques myard gilles casanova vous
restez avec jacques mignard mer les
républicains de maisons laffitte gilles
casanova expert en stratégie et
communication
on l'entendait au pakistan en indonésie
des appels finalement à tuer en france
notamment dans le sillage des
caricatures de charlie hebdo
gilles casanova au fond est ce qu'il
n'ya pas eu un terrible quiproquo avec
ces pays là puisque tous pensaient que
les caricatures était finalement montré
sur sur les façades de mur est ce que
finalement il y aurait pu avoir une
explication
côté français selon vous je ne crois pas
que ce soit là le coeur de la faire je
pense que c'est un incident qui n'est en
lui même pas le fond du problème je
crois qu'il y a une difficulté qui est
lié à la laïcité qui est une spécificité
française
nous sommes le seul pays qui dans sa
constitution qui dans son histoire dans
sa manière de vivre la vie est un pays
laïc c'est à dire qui fait une rupture
intégrale entre les églises et l'état
il n'y a pas d'autres états au monde
qu'ils le fassent
et cela c'est complètement insupportable
pour une partie des tenants de plusieurs
religions qui sont les intégristes
quelle que soit la religion concernée
les intégristes ne peuvent pas accepter
cette idée que la laïcité fait de la
religion
une chose qui est personnel et qui n'est
pas quelque chose qui va faire la
décision dans la sphère publique qui va
prendre les décisions pour gérer l'état
et la société
et ça c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
compris par un certain nombre de nos
amis américains
lisez les journaux américains lorsqu'ils
parlent de l'assassinât du professeur de
maisons de maisons laffitte leur par
exemple le new york times a titré la
police abat un homme qui n'avait qu'un
couteau
à la suite d'une attaque c'est à dire
qu'il pense que c'est notre police qui
est excessif c'est nous qui faisons des
affaires pour rien parce que nous sommes
dans des endroits où l'église les
églises l'état ne sont pas séparés et
cette idée de la laïcité qui est
extrêmement moderne
il nous faut la défendre or nous
constatons que dans notre pays la
tendance a été depuis 30 ans au
multiculturalisme
c'est à dire à dire que chacun a sa
culture
chacun voit midi à sa porte et chacun sa
propre histoire
non si nous ne disons pas l'histoire qui
est la nôtre c'est l'histoire de france
la culture qui est la nôtre c'est la
culture française c'est la culture de la
france qui veut y participer est le
bienvenu en apportant tout ce qu il a
avec lui
ça s'appelle l'assimilation c'est ce qui
fait que couscous et le plat préféré des
français ont fait une étude chaque année
pour savoir il était numéro trois il ya
15 ans numéro 2 il ya dix ans il est
aujourd'hui numéro un c'est un apport
qui visiblement pas celui la cuisine du
berry mais c'est quelque chose qui
participent qui est aujourd'hui fait
partie la culture française donc cette
assimilation
c'est ça qui fait un pays le
multiculturalisme c'est chacun garde sa
culture ce qui veut dire que dans cet
appart à une culture elles ont créé les
conditions d'un appart hyde effectif qui
fait qu'on retrouve cette idée que des
gens n'arrivent plus à donner un sens à
leur vie et veulent donner un sens à
leur mort et c'est ce qu'on voit
ensuite lorsqu'il y à des attentats
chaque milliard pour conclure en
quelques mots qu'est ce que vous
attendez
ce soir très concrètement de la part du
chef de l'état y du gouvernement comme
mesure en a marre je voudrais dire à
gilles casanova qui vient de parler je
dirais d'abord parce que effectivement y
compris avec des américains moi j'ai dû
me fâcher avec des américains qui peut
prendre à rien
rien puisque toute façon y compris sur
leur billet de bord qu'ils ont mis le
croyons en dieu bon d'accord mais je ne
sais pas si dieu crois en l'amérique
ce qui est certain c'est que ce que
j'attends du gouvernement c'est de
rétablir la souveraineté française en
matière juridique de manière à prendre
des mesures qui soient effectives
parce que c'est malheureux mais c'est
pas avec des bougies qu'on va combattre
ces gens là et nous devons mener une
politique culturelle extrêmement forte
pour expliquer ce qu'est son aux règles
et que si vous ne les acceptez pas eh
bien partez je voudrais rappeler que le
premier intégristes qui avait été abattu
par la gendarmerie à lyon qui elle avait
dit je ne peux pas vivre dans un pays où
on mange du porc
damman mieux si je veux pas vivre dans
un pays où on mange du porc
t'as qu'à prendre la sortie c'est aussi
simple que cela et c'est effectivement
ce n'est pas en admettant cette espèce
de salmigondis du multiculturalisme qui
conduisent nulle part il ya un moment il
faut dire c'est comme ça si vous n'êtes
pas d'accord partait mal assis merci à
tous les deux merci messieurs d'avoir
réagi en direct sur notre antenne merci
jacques mignard mère l'est républicain
de maisons laffitte
merci à vous gilles casanova expert en
communication il réalise est donc sur
notre antenne après cet attentat ce
matin à 9 heures